christine wir ging sie in den letzten
monaten also mal so mal so
ich hatte einfach wahnsinnig viel freie
zeit beruflich sehr sehr viel verschoben
wurde bzw gecancelt ausgefallen wurde
und dann steht mir natürlich finanziell
auch von der unsicherheit auch überhaupt
in dieser planungssicherheit ist als
freiberuflicher schauspieler sowieso
immer schwierig so zu langfristig zu
planen und was was kommt im nächsten
jahr wovon werde ich leben haben ein
extra bams engster auch teilweise ist
kam na ja ich bin für mich persönlich
bin ich ein sehr optimistisch gestimmte
mensch dass ich immer sage irgendwie
geht's für mich weiter und zur not mache
ich was anderes aber es ist natürlich
nicht jeder so eingestellt
und natürlich gab es auch mal immer so
moment wo ich dachte so misst und wie
sie es jetzt auf ein konto aus wie wird
es weitergehen und ja nicht nur für mich
persönlich sondern wirklich für die
gesamte branche also mit vielen vielen
kollegen mit denen ich geredet habe die
musiker zum beispiel ist auch so ein
fachgebiet fuß einfach ganz ganz
schwierig war jetzt mit den orchestern
wieder weiter zu machen und es ist
einfach so entsteht dann plötzlich vor 0
das haben sie denn hilfsgelder beantragt
haben sie das ich habe auch ich habe
diese sofort hilfe beantragt das hat ein
bisschen länger gedauert weil der antrag
für mich kompliziert da war als ich
dachte
aber ich habe dann tatsächlich auch was
bewilligt bekommen aber das hilft
natürlich
es ist eine überbrückung gewesen für
einen gewissen zeitrahmen und jetzt ist
einfach so der punkt wie wird es jetzt
weitergehen es in sachen immer noch also
es gibt immer noch was was ausgefallen
ist wo ich schon mit gerechnet hatte es
ist alles noch sehr sehr ungewiss und da
würde ich mir jetzt zum beispiel eben
wirklich vom staat wünschen dass man da
auch guckt wie kann man helfen zum
beispiel auch in dem punkt auf steuern
also ich habe im letzten jahr zum
beispiel sehr sehr viel selbstständig da
muss ich viele steuern zahlen die muss
ich jetzt eigentlich ein teil eben
zurückzahlen
und ich habe das geld momentan nicht
also so weil ich brauchte es einfach
jetzt gerade so zum leben und unter
einem möglichen das wird zum beispiel so
ein ansatz wo ich mir wünschen würde der
staat würde uns künstlern da in so einer
situation unter die arme greifen und
diese steuererleichterung wir können
nicht in kurzarbeit oder sonst was
[Musik]